PRESTON BAILEY:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I would like to start
by thanking Google
for this extraordinary
opportunity.
Very often, when I meet
people, and they say,
Preston, what do you do?
And I say, I design events.
And sometimes, they have
no idea what that is.
What does it mean,
design events?
To put it in simple
words, what I do
is create spaces that are
dramatic and beautiful enough
for a party.
It's just that simple.
Every single time that
I design an event,
my goal is always to
have the guests walk in
and say, oh my god, this is
the most incredible thing
that I've ever seen.
Mind you, this is
not always easy,
by the way, a lot of times,
especially with New Yorkers.
New Yorkers are a
little bit jaded.
They will walk into a
Preston Bailey space,
and they say, oh, here he goes
again, with lots of flowers.
But the goal is always to
amuse, entertain, and mostly--
and I think one of the
most successful events
that I do is those events that
the guests are so entertained
and they're so delighted that
they never want to leave.
How did I start?
I started because I was in
desperate need of a job.
It was 1980.
I was broke.
And a very good friend of
mine, the interior designer
Vicente Wolf,
suggested that I do
flowers for one of his clients.
That meant going to the floral
market in New York City,
picking up some flowers,
bringing it to the apartment,
and distributing it.
Well, to tell you the
truth, it was a nightmare.
I had absolutely no
idea what I was doing.
I went around these
clients' homes,
and at the end of the day,
I would get phone calls
like, Preston, the
flowers are dead.
I remember there was this one
client that I did her flowers
or did a party.
And she would come out
at the end of the day,
and she said, Preston,
what are those flowers?
And of course, I had
no idea what they were.
And I would make
it up, like, those
are floreleas from
South America.
But I went along.
Then, of course,
these are the '80s.
So the event industry was
just getting going there.
There were just florists.
That's how I started--
just doing flowers.
And then the '90s came.
And as far as I'm concerned,
a goddess was born.
A goddess by the name
of Martha Stewart.
Martha taught
America and the world
that it was perfectly fine
to go into your backyard,
pick up some leaves,
bring them to your table,
and decorate them.
I mean, this woman taught
America that they could cook.
She even taught us
how to make wine.
I mean, as far as I'm
concerned, she can do no wrong.
And have you noticed
she is much nicer
since she got out of jail?
She really, I mean this
woman has become so nice.
So the '90s came, and
as I struggled along
to get my business
on the ground,
I had the privilege of
meeting Joan Rivers.
And Joan Rivers was one of
my first clients that came in
and she said, Preston,
listen, I would
love to create this setting that
is so incredible that it looks
like an opera set, that whenever
my guests walk in, they say,
oh my god, this is just
the most incredible thing
that I've ever seen.
You can see one of the images
that almost 20 years later, I
think is still holds up.
The concept of event
designing started developing.
Not only was it important to do
beautiful flowers in a table,
when my client walked into
a ballroom and saw a room
and said, Preston,
I hate the walls.
I said, no problem.
We can change it.
I hate the ceiling.
Again, no problem,
we can change it.
And so emerged
within my business
what's called event designing.
For us, that is translated
in transforming a space.
A room that exists in a certain
way, and each time the guests
walk in, it looks different.
So today I have a few
images to show you
of the concept of
transformation.
Recently, we did an
event, a wedding.
And you have to understand that
for transformation, there's
a few things that we use.
One of the things that
we use is set design.
Other is lighting,
new technology,
but most importantly, flowers.
That is my tool.
The way that I design
and create a space
is very heavily flowers.
Why?
Because I love it.
If I could, I would just
cover the world with flowers.
It's that simple.
But anyhow, so this
event was over a pool,
and it was a ceremony.
And the client wanted us to
create this-- basically this
small building for her
daughter to get married.
And as you notice,
in this section,
we start creating with
thousands of orchids,
knitting them very carefully.
And finally, this is the
product that ended up.
And if you can see it
from different angles.
This is one angle.
Another one.
And as you look closer,
we created this chapel
for the wedding
of the gentleman.
Designing is about
creating surprises.
It's about creating
elements that you walk in,
and you're so in awe.
That is basically, I
think, the importance
of surprises in an event.
As we move along, if
you notice the detail.
This is all crystals and
flowers very carefully sewn in.
Tents.
I loved designing a tent.
Why?
You have this
perfectly blank canvas
that you could create
whatever you like.
But I think it's
not only the inside
of the tent that's important.
It's important also
to design the outside.
So, of course, in
this tent, we wanted
to create the feeling
of a glass house.
As the guests walked in,
this is the interior.
As we've been building
it, and of course,
the final project is this,
a clear looking space.
Transforming at tent.
Transforming a space.
And for the tables,
of course, we
did these tall accented pieces.
Another sample of
transformation is an event
that we did in the
south of France
that we created a ballroom
in a tennis court.
Ultimately the final
project is this.
And of course, creating certain
structure, the ceiling is open.
And of course, the
smallness of the table.
As we move on, we see a
ceiling transformation.
I did an event-- I happen
to love French gardens
by the way-- and while
doing this event,
I suggested to my
client that I wanted
to create a [INAUDIBLE]
garden in the ceiling.
And she thought I was
crazy, but anyhow,
this is the final product.
It's an empty ballroom, and
So what do I do?
What do I do?
My job is to take my clients'
fantasies and desires
and bring them to
reality, as much as I can.
I'm not always successful, but
I'll certainly keep trying.
We can see another
form of-- of course,
this is all of the
details of the wedding.
Another form of a restaurant
is the popular Nobu Restaurant
in 57th Street.
And they wanted to create
a winter wonderland.
And of course, this
is the final product.
The idea to having
the guests walk in
and absolutely not
recognizing the room.
As we move on, events.
What is so unique about events?
I think one of the great
things at the moment
is that there are these amazing
artists out there, by the way.
They're really, really
incredible people
that are creating
incredible work
that I consider to be artistic.
But anyhow, this is
an event that we did.
As a follow up, this is
a royal wedding actually
that we did in the Middle
East where the bride very
dramatically walked
down the aisle.
She sits in the throne.
This is the area that
she came out from.
This one, I think, is
really very interesting
because we did it
in Jakarta, and I
wanted to create
a sculpture that
did not involve
any flowers at all.
And I basically purchased
literally 10,000 light bulbs,
and anyhow, we created
this installation which,
in Chinese, means
double happiness,
creating a dramatic statement.
Of course, this was for the
party portion of the evening.
As a surprise, the guests walked
in and saw this sculpture.
This is an event in New York
City at the Waldorf Astoria,
transforming the ballroom
from this to this.
And of course the tails
are very important.
The ceiling, if you see, we
created this starry night.
As we move on, this
is a wonderful event
that we did that we wanted
the impression of moving
from spring to winter.
So as the guests walked
in, this is what they saw.
As the evening progressed,
it turned into spring.
Using technology, lighting,
every single new technology
that emerged, we try to
incorporate in creating events.
As we move on, so we went from
flowers to transformation.
And there's a new part
of the business that
is emerging that I find that
is incredibly interesting.
So a lot of clients
and also businesses,
they want to create a temporary
structure, just for one event.
A lot of times, they
call it pop-up place.
They might keep
it up for a week.
Sometimes they'll keep
it up for a month.
But there's a couple of
structures that we designed.
One of them that I
did, a bubble tent
that is the size
of a football field
in the middle of the desert.
And as you walk in the
tent, this is what you see.
And if you notice
in this image, one
of the fun things
that I created was
to create a dance floor that is
made out of all flowers, that
is covered that
people could dance,
and it basically was
made out of all flowers.
This structure stayed up
for at least three weeks.
And another structure that
we built also is of course--
and this, by the way, is at
least 20 to 30 feet high--
so as we're building
it of course,
and then this is
the final product.
And one of the beautiful
things about the inside
of the structure is that
the ceiling was retractable,
meaning that at one point we had
actually fireworks that amused
and entertained the guests.
As we move on, this
is another section.
The dance was a
little bit more fun.
I was so surprised
one day when I
got a phone call and somebody
suggested that maybe I
should start doing
public exhibits.
And one of the problems
with the events that I
do-- it's not really a
problem-- but one of the issues
is, of course,
that it's only seen
by a certain amount of
guests, which is great
because these guests
leave, and they
will carry this in
their memory forever.
But the public exhibits
for the reason that I like
is because there's more
than many people that
comes to see it in many days.
So this one is one that
we did in Los Angeles,
just a few orchids, not a lot.
And as you see, and again
the peacock concept took off,
and we did another version
in the south of France,
and another version in
Covent Garden in London.
We did move on from
peacocks, and we
created this bridal design
at the public library
at New York City.
And even when you
come into my office,
you see my dogs on my desk.
This is my desk, by the way.
These are the best dogs --
you don't have to walk them.
And, of course, this
is an installation
that we did in Jakarta
with 500,000 butterflies.
We created this large
structure in the middle--
of course they weren't live,
these butterflies-- this is my
[INAUDIBLE].
So anyhow, for the
new year in Hong Kong,
we created these installations.
Of course, it was
the year of the horse
that we created
this installation.
At the moment, at the
Wynn in Las Vegas,
Mr. Wynn, which as far as I'm
concerned is a brilliant man,
had the idea of creating
this hot air balloon made out
of 100% flowers.
And also, he also created
a carousel made out
of all flowers.
And of course the carousel is
all mobile, and it goes around.
For me, this is an
amazing opportunity
to be able to create my
work from florist to event
design and, of course,
now it translate
into the public installation.
This is the most recent wedding
that I did for Mr. Sean Parker.
Mr. Sean Parker I think is
a brilliant, brilliant guy,
and he just wanted to
create the ultimate wedding
that we had in Big Sur.
In Big Sur-- this is Mr.
Parker and his wife--
the entire theme of the
event was Game of Throne.
The images-- everyone was
dining outside in the park.
As you move along,
this is a night image.
This is the ceremony area.
As we move on, we see
them getting married.
So I think it's very
tricky to do weddings
outdoor, and the reason why is
because it's so vast that you
have to create statements that
are so powerful that you could
actually see the decor.
This is the traditional space.
And of course, this is at night,
the wonderful lighting creating
a fun event.
So what do I do?
What do we do?
I have a company that the
main purpose is to entertain.
The main purpose of my company
is to get into my clients' head
and truly try to
see what's there
in order to bring
it out for life.
OK.
Thank you so much.
Now some questions, if
anyone has questions.
AUDIENCE: Welcome to Google.
PRESTON BAILEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm very interested
in your project management
process, because we
do a lot of projects
here, not at the scale
of a football size,
but it could be analogous.
What are some of the
project management
tips that you can share with
us today that we could possibly
apply to say, software
development or even
client development?
PRESTON BAILEY: I think that's
a very good question actually.
Creating a project is a
very, what should I say,
linear process.
First you have to
decide what is it
that you're trying to
promote, what is it
sell, or what ideas
that you're trying to promote.
Once you have that, I think
it's a matter of going back.
What I normally do, I create
a storyboard with everything
that comes to mind.
I get together with
my design team.
If we're designing
a corporate event,
if we're designing
an opening, we
look at all of the
elements that exist
that we need to replicate.
Once we do that, then
comes the fantasy portion.
How can we create something
that, either out of flowers
or of lighting, that
tells the story,
that tells the story in
a way that it's noticed.
As you notice, most of my
job is not understated.
There's nothing
understated about my job.
But I think when I first
started, even though I could
not do all of this, I always
try to create one statement that
tells the story, whatever
that statement could be.
And once you have that
one-- it could be out of,
as I said, out of flowers.
It could be told
in different ways.
Once you have that
statement, then you
could just go from there.
I design it.
I meet with the client.
I present it to them.
The presentations for
me is very serious.
Usually I give them not only
one but three different designs.
I love designing.
So does my team, so
it's not a problem.
They will choose at least
one, and sometimes they
like all of them.
And whenever that happens,
they will choose elements
from each one of them in
order to make it real.
But I think from a
creative point of view,
you should just
go crazy designing
until you feel that you
really get the right one.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PRESTON BAILEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious what's either
been the most challenging and/or
your favorite installation
or design, and why.
PRESTON BAILEY: Right.
I've always said that
my most challenging job
is the one that I'm working at.
And the reason is
a very simple one.
We've come up with these great
ideas and this scale thing,
and the reality of it is that
I've never seen it before.
So for us to see that
process come to life,
it's very nerve wracking.
Recently, I had a very
traumatic experience, actually
in Florida.
We did an event in Florida, and
we built this beautiful tent
with these big,
hanging structures
with flowers and crystals
and everything else.
And all week, all week
it threatened to rain,
but nothing came.
The moment the guests starting
walking into the tent,
it poured, but not only poured
but with a wind that literally
everything was
swinging like this.
And my client was
standing beside me,
and she's in a panic.
And I'm like, it's OK,
nothing's going to fall.
Meanwhile, I was
absolutely freaking out.
And the reason I
say this, is for me,
seeing that job come
to life is exciting,
because my favorite
job, because I'm
seeing it for the first time.
And also I think the risk
of things going wrong.
No one wants to admit
that things go wrong.
That's a lie.
Every single job that I've
done, things have happened.
So for me, seeing an event come
to life is an exciting process,
and usually that
is my favorite one.
Once that's said, I think one of
the most fun party that we did
is something that we did
for Oprah a while ago
that I thought was incredible.
OK.
Good.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Your work it's
absolutely stunning.
PRESTON BAILEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And clearly
you have good fortune
to work with very large budgets.
So if you didn't, if you
were constrained with budget,
what would be some
suggestions you'd
have for others
given that situation?
PRESTON BAILEY: And this
is a blessing and also
a curse to have
this large project.
It really is.
But I think that
everyone forgets
that when I first started,
I only had like $100
to work with.
Two years later, I had $200.
$500, years later.
The budgets kept
growing very slowly.
So I think designing, it's
not a matter of budget.
Clearly you can have much
more fun with lots of budget.
But it's really
a matter of being
able to allocate whatever you
want to spend, and spend it
wisely.
That's it.
It's just as simple as that.
If you can't do this set
design, do it with candles.
A very easy way to
transform this room,
if I get 500 votive candles and
just put them over, that's it.
That's a decoration.
And each candle
costs what, 50 cents?
So it's really not a
matter of the budget--
it's really a matter of taking
whatever resources you have,
try to be as inventive
as you possibly can.
And you could come up
with something fun.
OK.
And again, another
advice that I have
is the elements that you use.
Try to use elements
that are inexpensive
but just repeat them a lot.
As I just said,
with votive candles,
if you just do a lot of
votive, you have a design.
If you want to use
flowers, try to get
a flower that is very cheap.
Separate them,
repeat them, you also
have a design that is impactful.
And you have to
decide if you want
a design that is
understated or impactful.
I go for the second.
OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello again.
Do you let your ideas
flow and go along
as you start planning
an event, or do you
have everything in
place before you start?
And are you in
competition with yourself?
PRESTON BAILEY: That's
a very good question.
Years ago, I used to
hear from my clients--
I would do this job
and present it to them,
and the day of the
event they would walk in
and say, Preston, this is
not what I had in mind.
And I learned the hard way
that I do not leave anything
for surprise or for chance.
The process is, the client hired
me, they gave me a deposit.
Once they do, I start designing,
and I do it by renderings.
We use all the
different programs,
and we give them at least three
choices, all in rendering.
Once they choose what
they like, then we
set up either small settings,
tables, pieces of the event,
to actually show them.
We usually photograph
it, and give them a copy
and we keep a copy.
This way, there is
no room for, this
is not what we have in mind.
We try to show them everything
as much as possible.
And as far as my
ideas, I think, I'm not
one of those designers
that walks into a room,
and it's, this is it.
Not at all.
Usually I have to work for it.
I usually go into the
space, hang out there
for a day or two.
Come back, create a story,
and it develops from there.
It's something that comes
not-- you have to work for it.
I envy those designers
that they come up,
and they got it immediately.
For me, it's more of
a process of sitting
with it, go for a
run, go to the gym.
I think about it.
I write in the
morning, and then it
starts developing
into something.
OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So obviously every
event and every project
seems to be very
different, but what's
kind of your typical timeline
from that first meeting
you have with a client
up into the execution
of the event itself?
PRESTON BAILEY: Right.
A comfortable
timeline, I think, is
anything from six
months to a year.
I think that is a
comfortable timeline.
We have had events-- I think
we did-- what did we do?
Actually, a few years ago,
I did Mr. Trump's wedding,
and we had one month.
Literally he came in and
said, we want to get married.
What can you do?
Mr. Trump.
We threw everything
together of course.
And it was a very rapid process.
Also, I think you could err
in having too much time.
Which is great, I love
to be booked two years
in advance, one year in advance.
I think it's great.
It's good for business.
But to tell you the truth,
your design sensitivity
changes in two years.
Things that I like
now, I didn't like
two years ago and vice versa.
But I think six months
to a year is comfortable,
not only from a
design point of view,
but for my pricing
point of view.
I could certainly
design the job,
price it out carefully,
competing prices
to see which one is best.
And if we do something
at last minute,
I usually have to
rush and just buy
whatever the first thing--
use the vendor that
first comes to mind.
But to answer your question,
I think six months to a year
is a very comfortable time.
OK.
AUDIENCE: What was the
most surprising event
you were ever asked to design?
Because it looks like
weddings, and then
corporate events,
and then holidays.
Is there one that
sticks out that was
something you hadn't thought of?
PRESTON BAILEY: I
had a client once
that invited me and a
group of her best friends
to go to an island--
I think it was
Grenada, one of those islands.
And they had a private
plane, and everybody
jumped into the private plane.
What no one knew is
that we had decorated
the plane for a wedding.
So while they were flying
to their destination,
while they were
flying, they actually
got married in the plane, which
I thought was really cool.
Another time that is a
little bit of a sad story,
but I think it also was fun.
There was this couple
that I did a wedding for,
and their families
were fighting a lot.
So they decided to
come to me and for us
to design a Preston Bailey
wedding with everything.
And the two of them
got married alone.
So in a way, they
eloped by themselves.
But they really went
crazy with the design.
And later, they took videos,
and they invited both families,
had a big party and
showed the wedding
to them, which I thought that
was such a good solution.
And they had a great time.
They had a 30 piece band.
I mean they really
did it as if it
was a wedding for 300 people.
And then later on, of course,
they had a private party.
I thought that was pretty cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PRESTON BAILEY: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: I can't
get to the mic.
PRESTON BAILEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Where do you
get your inspiration from?
You have a great sense
[INAUDIBLE] design team,
but where do your next
ideas spring from?
PRESTON BAILEY: I get my
inspiration from drugs.
No, I'm kidding.
That is a joke.
Where do I get my inspiration?
Several places.
I mean, clearly images.
First of all, Pinterest,
which, by the way,
is like a friend and an
enemy at the same time.
Why?
Because these ladies walk
in with all of these images,
that either they want the exact
same thing, which I don't do.
And I usually say, no, we
can't do the same thing.
But I think that the
good thing about them
is that they are full of ideas.
The theater.
I love fashion.
I look at fashion.
Just a matter of
paying attention.
I'm walking down
the street, and I'm
seeing what are
the ladies wearing
and what are the
colors of the season.
It's really a matter of
being present where you are.
Luckily, at the moment
I do travel a lot,
and I have the
privilege of visiting
these incredible cultures that
have the most inspiring ideas.
Recently, for the first
time, I came from Bahrain,
for instance.
And again the entire culture is
just amazing in their design,
in the prints.
So it's really a
matter of taking ideas
from every place, especially
when you're designing a job.
You're paying more attention
to whatever is around you.
But the main inspiration
for me comes from nature.
If you see my work,
it's very nature driven.
Years ago, I went to Washington
for the cherry blossom weekend.
I don't know if you've
ever been there.
If you haven't, you should.
I saw the most incredible trees
and absolutely rows and rows
of cherry blossoms.
And at that moment,
I said, imagine
what it would be like to have
that beauty and bring it in.
And for that reason, most
of my work tends to be so--
or I try anyway-- to
make it very powerful.
That you walk in, and
it's like, oh my god,
this is like so incredible.
So nature is really a big
force of my inspiration.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any tips
for designing in a smaller
space?
PRESTON BAILEY: Yes.
Yes, yes yes.
There's such a
basic, simple trick
about designing smaller space.
Uplight the walls.
You take this room.
You notice that it's
in darkness right now.
If I just uplit the walls,
immediately it gives it depth.
And it's the same thing
with a small space.
Immediately it starts
looking bigger.
So visually it
changes immediately.
Also, people make the
mistake that in small spaces,
they put a lot of things in.
You should do the opposite.
Try to empty it as
much as possible
and just create elements
that are valuable,
elements that are going to
tell a story, a statement.
But those are the
two basic things
that I think are very
effective in creating
a space that is not very big.
And again, whenever you have any
question, just use candlelight.
Uplight the walls, and
just use lots of candles.
Why?
Do you have a--?
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
PRESTON BAILEY: I'm curious.
I would help you
if you wanted to.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
PRESTON BAILEY:
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks a lot.